[Musique]
aline l'homme en noir
bienvenue dans la vie à bord du canal
happy hour le premier jeu basé sur la
vie de ces candidats
ces équipes qui vont s'affronter ce soir
sont
le ventilateur le plus puissant de
france
claudia tagbo
[Applaudissements]
allez le plus grand écrivain français
vivant yann moix
ea mateur avec une belle hauteur de
plafond
stéphane plaza
[Applaudissements]
selon li cinéma français jean benguigui
ces deux équipes de personnalités vont
jouer sur le thème qu'elle préfère elle
même
l'enjeu est simple l'équipe gagnante
aura le droit de faire plus de promo que
l'autre alors stéphane par exemple votre
promo ça serait quoi pour voir les
bouffes parisiens jean votre promo moi
c'est un bouquin qui est surtout celle
paillard un parfum d'orange amère etc et
signé de bons non ça serait dommage que
vous n'en parlez pas c'est dommage parce
que tout le monde veut que j'en parle je
sais
yann ça serait quoi vous rendre les
oeuvres complètes pour les havrais
complète ouais et vous cloud ya un mois
ce serait les folies bergères donc du 29
janvier tous ces gens là ont des choses
à vendre mais ils sont pas sûrs de
l'évent
cigale vous êtes prêt à gagner oui je te
ra to hope hatouma gagner oui way dont
est prête ou toute
[Applaudissements]
première épreuve le bio quiz
attention le principe est simple chacun
d'entre vous vers l'objet de deux
questions sur sa vie mais ce sera à
notre équipe de répondre évidemment un
point par bonnes réponses on commence
avec votre vie avoue ses fans claudiane
c'est donc à vous de répondre
stéphane plaza fait l'agent immobilier à
la télé ce n'est pas un rôle de
composition stéphane est un vrai agent
immobilier d'ailleurs c'est sur un salon
professionnel que jean luc delarue l'a
repéré en 2005 et c'est comme ça qu'il a
atterri sur m6 mais son premier passage
à la télé c'était sur tf1
à 30 ans stéphane plaza a témoigné dans
l'émission c'est quoi l'amour quel était
le thème de l'émission ce jour là j'ai
30 ans et je suis toujours puceau
je suis amoureux de ma mère je n'ai
jamais vécu avec une femme et je ferais
n'importe quoi pour passer à la
télévision peut être les quatre ensemble
techniquement c'était possible
[Musique]
je suis encore plus haut
à 30 ans
[Musique]
non mais c'est possible c'est possible
mais peu je le regarde comme sa faune
ont quand même
je suis amoureux de ma mère peut être
parce que c'est un garçon qui est donné
je ferais n'importe quoi pour passer à
la télévision il y passe en ce moment en
faisant n'importe quoi oui
[Applaudissements]
donc je vais expliquer qu'après aussi
joie
allait passer mais vu que les femmes
ouais ouais moi je veux suivre mais je
pense que c'est je suis amoureux de ma
mère quelle est votre réponse alors je
n'ai jamais vécu avec une femme on a
délaissé
[Applaudissements]
c'était en 2001 et stéphane boulade y
ait jamais vécu avec une femme non
depuis on va avec tout
attention c'est dans cette émission de
carole rousseau que stéphane a lancé à
l'assistance j'aime bien une petite pipe
le matin qui n'aimerait pas une petite
pipe le matin franchement à
aujourd'hui stéphane fais beaucoup plus
attention à ce qu'il dit de quoi
stéphane plaza par le tir quand il dit
je l' ai souvent fait seul et encore
maintenant de son jogging quotidien de
l'acte sexuel du ménage chez lui ou de
sa fête d'anniversaire
j'ai vu
le centre jeudi un quotidien fait sa
fête d'anniversaire tout seulement là
maintenant il a vaincu une femme
mais aussi à persuader qu'il a toujours
30 ans à d'accord c'est triste fois il
est gentil où il est très sympathique
mais il a fait pas envie de voir les
années qui partit
à l'aider
[Musique]
mon métier c'est étonnant comme on
tente de faire passer quand même ça te
sens inverse à tout se sait c'est triste
ouais c'est que stéphane fait tout seul
et c'est encore plus triste que dia
c'est l'acte sexuel
et il va vous expliquer comment ça se
passe oui tu fais toujours seul nom
adacore n'a encore de le faire tout ça
oui là tout le monde bien sûr mais ça me
dégoûte de l'audition
l'année mais
je continue à jouer mais cette fois avec
la vie de jean benguigui
jean est né le 8 avril
1944 à oran comme bon nombre de pieds
noirs et garde un souvenir ému bien j'ai
de son enfance algérienne qu'il a
récemment raconté dans un livre
l'autobiographie de jean benguigui
s'intitule un parfum de l'autre rive un
parfum de couscous boulette
parfum de fleur d'oranger ou un parfum
d'orange amère
et
bravo
enfants
jamais le livre de jean tous formidables
d'ailleurs vous raconter toute
l'histoire quoi je raconte mon enfance
puis jusqu'à mon arrivée à paris mes
débuts dans le métier puis la suite
jusqu'à aujourd'hui même à jean
benguigui fait partie de cette catégorie
d'acteurs dont on se dit quel
film j'avais vu lui normal qu'on trouve
familier il a joué dans plus de 100
films à la télé et au cinéma
je demande du respect ici
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi c'est que parfois jean
benguigui fait du doublage
au cinéma jean benguigui
a doublé
marlon brando dans le para
tio pesci dans les affranchis
danny devito dans jumeaux rocco siffredi
la demi vie de huit heures aussi je
serai c 'est donne de vito et c'est non
non
il a doublé chow tai chi dans les
affronts si
[Applaudissements]
vous avez des questions désolé ma voix
le monde dans les aigus comme emblème
voilà il a fait comme ça
mélangez
on va regarder danny devito dans jumeaux
souffle et 1
parce que c'était parti
question la vague et
regarde plus et des pervers ça fait 2
point pour vous sur quatre
on continue avec vous que le diable si
stéphane et jean qui désormais à vont
devoir répondre
à la base
claudia et comédienne la jouer dans un
film au titre meetic la valse des gros
derrière c'est sans doute sa prestation
dans un film qui a incité djamel à la
recruter dans son comedy club en 2006
depuis 2012 elle se produit par son en
france avec son spectacle crazy c'est un
triomphe pas étonnant qu'elle soit
autant demander pour participer à des
événements culturels
en 2012
[Musique]
claudia tagbo à défiler
au salon du mafé
au salon de la coiffure à au salon du
chocolat ou au salon du thouet rck
alors
vieux chais la tête
j'ai tout chocolat chocolat tchoco
tchoco la bonne réponse
claudia avait déclaré aux journalistes
qui l'attendait en bas du podium je suis
tout en chocolat vas-y lèche mois
[Applaudissements]
et à la télé va pas
claudia les a tous fait craquer en fait
djamel jean luc lemoine arthur fabrice
éboué et même un delon qu'elle a
embrassé sur la bouche à la télé on va
voir nom qui est son préféré
mais de qui parles claudien quand elle
dit j'adore ce mec il me touche gad
elmaleh
arthur
jamel debbouze ou omar sy
sam est touchant on est tous sens
je pense à marcy pas aussi aux mars omar
sy mauvaise réponse si tu tues
mais c'est un mec qui est touchant c'est
arthur il touche mais est-ce qu'il est
touchant
oui trouver quoi tu touches arthur aller
on a toute la soirée
[Rires]
oui aux dépens des relations claires on
a appris les gens mais qu'elles sont
hors là-dessus rythme mais déjà on
travaille ensemble et puis il est
toujours étonné toujours à l'affût de ce
qui va se passer voilà très curieux tout
savoir ou est ce qu'on peut payer moins
d'impôts
il est très à l'affût mais
a trouvé
là même si on termine avec l'avis de
yann
stéphane et jean c'est toujours à vous
de répondre en 2013 yann moix a remporté
la reconnaissance de ses pairs avec son
livre naissance prix renaudot
la même récompense que ses idoles céline
ragon butor frédéric hébété
près de dix ans auparavant il avait créé
la polémique avec un roman où il
établissait un lien entre le terrorisme
et la peur du plaisir sexuel
en 2004 yann moix a écrit un livre
intitulé
because
partouze père loose
c'est partout on le voit partout sur
nintendo partners d'ailleurs osé du
français
[Applaudissements]
on ne ressent à travers sa plume et dans
ses interviews
yann est un obsessionnel compulsif
on peut même dire qu'il est maniaque
attention yann moix est drôle de manie
les bateaux fils c'est à dire qu'il
mémorise un nombre ahurissant de date il
est râteau fils collectionne les râteaux
il est script au fil dire qu'il
collectionne les titres sans valeur
boursière où il est trop tôt fils il
ramasse les crottes crottes de chien
dans la rue il aimait dans un kleenex il
les collectionne il est donc trop tôt
fils alors moi je suis plutôt pour le
date au film c'est sûr tu en penses
pleine tête à savoir les dates mais
c'est un espèce de manière dont on fait
de la merde au titre
cette contemplation des questions
à l'essai à manière de la connaissance
si vous êtes un vrai bateau fille la
date de sortie au cinéma de podium je
dirais on s'est vrillé 2004 trop fort
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup plus vision sa
sortie de cinéma d'hier et 27 octobre
et
les deux c'était un mercredi
ce qui est arrivé à l'issue du bio
couiza les scores sont relativement bas
lancé il ya quand même que nous tentons
route pas pour vous
gagnant gagnant et voilà on se retrouve
tout de suite après la bulle pour la
suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous re bienvenus
[Applaudissements]
le premier jeu basé sur la
nous sommes toujours en compagnie du
ventilateur le plus puissant de france
diatta
le plus grand écrivain français vivent
bien moi
l'animateur avec une belle hauteur de
plafond
et le plus grand second rôle du cinéma
français
mika
deux points pour vous
pour toi
pour le moment on en profite pour la
star profitez-en pour le pensez vous
qu'il ferait le plus de promo ouais on
peut commencer non
on continue à piller à voir avec la
deuxième épreuve qui s'appelle l'auto
quiz
alors le principe est très simple
chacun d'entre vous aura 60 secondes
pour répondre à un maximum de questions
en rapport avec sa vie bien entendu
chaque bonne réponse rapporte un point
on va voir si vous vous connaissez bien
vous même stéphane c'est votre tour de
répondre moi c'est justement on commence
par mois vous êtes prêts
moi je suis frais des prêts
vous souvenez-vous du prénom de la
première fille dont vous êtes tombé
amoureux à l'école maternelle oui
stéphanie bravo
combien d'années avait vu travailler
dans l' agence immobilière raison
qu'elle quotidien publie un portrait de
loi intitulé stéphane plaza agent double
libération bravo donc quel théâtre
indien avez vous joué pour la première
fois à gauche en sortant de l'ascenseur
saint georges qui a écrit cette pièce
n'osiez combien y at-il de l'être dans
votre prénom et votre nom 1 2 3 4 de 8 9
10 11 cette ost e
meilleur tu peux passer un bon je
passe à quel âge as-tu entré à
polytechnique
j'ai le droit de passer nerfs gds un peu
revenir
on et faire plein on y passe mais
maintenant il va compter pour de vrai
vas-y
oui mais qui fait d'eux les appartements
quand même
c'est pas intéressé par les commissions
major donc apporter mal à vendre en
exclusivité
quel est le prénom de la fille de votre
très bonne amie karine le marchand
alliant aller en 2010 avait été lue
jeunes talents dans la catégorie
animateur télé vous devez cette
récompense aux lecteurs de quel magazine
figaro tv mag les mecs et
là c'est horrible ce qui se passe qu'est
ce qu'il ya sur ces gens là oui vous
n'appelez leurs animateurs mais je n'y
ai pas trop si c'est quel journal nikkei
non
c'est vexant pour journal oui pour moi
aussi alors tout le monde sait pas de
mémoire il ya un malaise à
télé poche
sur la conversion de vote libre maison à
vendre le mot maison et écrits de quelle
couleur rose ouais et sur la conversion
notre autre lit recherche alors
trop fort quel est le premier
[Applaudissements]
n'est pas m'as l'air de rien mais je
veux dire je suis épaté par sa culture
générale
maintenant quand les gens arrivent à
répondre à des questions sur leur faim
le reste il s'en est capable s'intéresse
à quelque chose
et voilà on continue avec jean bédard
est présent ouais j'ai pas de mémoire
attention
les jurés dans demande qu'à en rire
citez moi l'un des deux comiques qui a
obtenu la note censure sans
arnaud tsamère et puis jérémy ferrari
ouais j'ai réglé
non qu'elle filme avec joie un
personnage nommé mimoun dans nos jours
de nakache et toledano voir
dans tout votre filmographie quel est le
film qui a fait le plus gros carton au
box office
astérix bravo à ces règles d'achat la
belle chabat le meilleur qui ait eu des
aciéries vous qui avez doublé savoir
comment s'appelait le personnage de joe
pesci dans les affranchis
aucun souvenir famille de vito au total
combien de spectacle avez-vous fait avec
patrice chéreau
cinq hommes
[Applaudissements]
ksm le tibia épisode de navarro dans
lequel vous avez joué les poubelles de
l'aube quelque chose comme ça je jouais
loulou nicollin mur de poubelles je sais
pas
et s'ils font les chiffonniers de
l'offre
mais moi ça m'a tellement
j'ai merdé non c'est non à bagdad à 15
verres soufflés
je viens c'est à votre tour de jouer
d'accord reste vous êtes prête oui
donc quel long métrage votre personnage
s'appelait hassiba à laval ses gros
derrière
ça m'a vexé quand on vous a prises pour
ce rôle non parce que j'avais lu le
scénario donc je sais ce qu'il y avait
dedans c'est elle attrape couillon qu'on
a fait ça parce que du coup nous on
connaissait l'histoire c'est dès qu'il
est réalisateur du film genre ou du
temps bravo dans quel théâtre avez vous
tourné la soirée
claudia tagbo à niko ah ça c'est un
maillot vert que la dernière fois
c'était la cigale après parce que les
folies bergères pas quel quotidien tu
crées sur vous claudia tagbo une glace
au parfum j vrai
j'aime bien j'ai le jeu passe parisien
va fallu 20 minutes d'accord comment
s'appelait votre personnage dans le film
les seigneurs ah oui ça tout à tout
moment dongo
connais bien sûr les lunettes lors d'un
passage dans l'émission la parenthèse
inattendue qui étaient les deux autres
invités à les y avait didier barbelivien
et
à
un journaliste on françois jeune france
par sa soeur catherine laborde bravo
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas juste parce qu'avec moi vous
avez été super lent avec lui vous avez
fait julien lepers autant c'est le jeu
ma pauvre lucette
c'était bien appris que c'était bien la
marque est ce un point comme dit il en
posant les questions quand même
et comme je suis la seule fille du
plateau soit 3 points de plus
se déguiser en fait il nous tous et pour
avoir les trois points
dans ce genre termine avec vous la
jetterait les mémoires d'enfer à huy
avec combien de voix allez-vous remporté
le prix renaudot dès le premier tour je
croise étaient six ouais sur rien 10
c'est quoi que non le renaudot et aux
phrases barrot lors de votre passage
dans salut les terriens à quelle
interview formaté avez vous été soumis
tir aux pigeons ward
dans cette interview quelle personne
invitée avait vous décrit comme une
paire de lunettes rester sur le carreau
je ne connais qu'elle
audrey pulvar bravo
toujours dans cette interview
comment avez-vous des cris alessandra
sublet une feuille de laitue dans une
laitue qui regarde sa feuille bravo
quel magazine a publié un article sur
vous intitulé et moix et moix et moix et
moi tous mais dont marianne way tous
l'express marianne l'express que tenez
vous dans la main sur la photo de votre
page wikipédia un livre je peux vous
dire lequel c'est c'est saint paul
simple lettre aux corinthiens
fait votre livre naissance 1143
et a dit de vous
à
l'insu de l'auteur claude
y ait une incroyable 2 à 15 15 mai born
on sait
déjà tout va bien franchement on
continue avec la troisième épreuve le
duo quiz
alors le principe est très simple vous
lance une affirmation vous devez me dire
lequel des membres de l'autre équipe
cela concerne ou bien aucun des deux
chaque bonne réponse rapporte un point
on va voir si vous connaissez vos
adversaires on commence avec vous
stéphane et jean lequel des deux a un
nom de famille qui signifie la panthère
en bambara
claudia
chez moi
[Rires]
la pente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on m'ignore
sympathique attention parmi vous avez a
certes lequel des deux genres mais je
sais déjà fait éjecter de facebook si on
a ça ce riad est engorgé ni l'un ni
l'autre voilà j'ai dit entre les deux
mais alors qu'on signale anigo
[Musique]
à
manger
j'ai une foi et sur son addition tu vois
mes bêtes pas toi tu connais laurent
blanc durant 30 jours à ces annonces
pour des poilus comment ils nous parlent
mais peter lynn est dingue ce mec il
peut que se faire virer de facebook et
de twitter de tous aux dires mêmes du
tattoo le sa vérité
parmi vos adversaires lequel des deux
c'est déjà fait éjecter d'une réunion
d'alcooliques anonymes ils sont tous les
deux alcooliques dont ils ont par aucun
des deux aucun des deux aucun des deux
supports possibles aucun titre
[Applaudissements]
à l'hôpital trop et après avoir garni
envieux
parmi nous je versais lequel des deux
parraine l'association ela contre les
maladies rares
la panthère quand ça peut être josiane
où aucun des deux c'est peu dire ouais
je le sais
mais aussi
[Applaudissements]
par les adversaires lequel des deux a
déclaré sa flamme à son ou sa bien aimée
en lui écrivant sur le bitume une lettre
d'amour de sept kilomètres de long au
moyen d'un pistolet à peinture
possible ça non je crois pas aucun des
deux
yann moix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
57 m le jour du bac d'une jeune fille
dont il est amoureux quand j'étais
moi-même bacheliers et entre olive et où
elle habitait et orléans il y avait sept
kilomètres donc comme je savais qu'elle
allait au lycée en vélo sur les 7 km
j'ai écrit sur bitume mais ce journal
est allé au lycée en bagnole donc
merci de la pécho avec sept kilomètres
quand même tué à pécho bah oui quand
même ah mais papa grâce à sa préfère pas
savoir
parmi vous avez un cerf lequel des deux
a failli se faire dévorer par des
crocodiles pendant son enfance
moi je ne dis rien c'est l'ex la rue
après avoir jugé
étant moi même j'ai failli boualam est
dévorée par des crocodiles au kenya
pendant du toit de l'afrique un ouais
donc je sais que des blancs peuvent être
aussi
jésus c'est claudia dans le choix entre
être raciste ou alors une mauvaise
réponse
quand on dit claudia délit claudia vous
pensez que tu as fait dévorer par
ces personnes
aucun des
[Applaudissements]
deux l'a balancé mais qu'elles sont la
rencontre au quotidien
l'union saint gilloise
super héros parmi vos adversaires se
caler deux manches du mafé tous les
meubles j'obtiens
une auquel mange des noix de coco
claudia
alors le score il est de 17 pour vous
est de 15 pour gobain
continue le dieu au quiz
[Applaudissements]
allez-vous jian alors vous êtes prêts
oui parmi vous adversaire lequel des
deux a déjà déclaré à la télévision
qu'il aimait commencé sa journée par une
petite fée nation
un peu lasse t phone parce que lui c'est
pas autre chose mais il a dit c'est toi
là il a déclaré et c'est comme si ça
peut pas être jean ces personnes
c'est toujours plate
mais bien faire mais quand des deux a
déjà déclaré à la télévision qui aimait
bien finir sa journée par un petit gang
bang attention c'est être un piège oui
le petit nom c'est un grand groupe tisse
et des personnes
yanis et qu'il n'y a pas de petits dons
parmi nous amener à st
lequel des deux est marié depuis 22 ans
avec la petite soeur de roger hanin
navale à 10
[Musique]
ans excellente balle et on va faire
comme le congo dit on va dire jean
aucun
adversaire lequel v de la réussit
l'exploit de vendre un appart avec vue
sur le sacré coeur à gilbert montagné
[Musique]
aucun des deux os non
t'as pas fait ça
à aucun des deux géants
ornés nos adversaires lequel des deux a
eu un papa champion de cyclisme
professionnel ça c'est difficile
waouh
pas peur des crocodiles tu vas pas avoir
peur d'eux tu as raison mais
la poésie balance bien truc choisi
des pédales c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
si les adversaires lequel avait déjà
doublé un dessin animé
[Musique]
j'en sais trop facile aucun des deux
dirigeants d'accord moi je dirais stefan
gp prendront fin moi je dis gens bon
alors vous êtes vous d'accord mais je te
laisse non non non non non non après
et va m'accuser d'un blog j'étais dans
le des non dits et stéphanie l'a dit
stéphane vraiment stéphane moi je pense
que ces gens
allaient chum stéphane ces gens méritent
à
riche ap des scores 18 pour 17 points
qui font la promo
pour l'instant va pas finir
battant c'est la pub en sortons
bien
le premier jeu basé sur la vie
ces candidats
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue
damian wayne rooney
[Applaudissements]
le ses candidats nous sommes toujours en
compagnie du ventilateur le plus
puissant
les plus grands écrivains français
vivant
les lutteurs de plafond
tu sais maman c'est vous
18 pour vous 17 pour vous et on passe à
lardy quiz
c'est très facile tout le monde joue en
même temps je suis une interview à ma
façon
j'appuie sur le buzzer quand vous avez
la bonne réponse pas une contrainte ce
soir toutes les réponses devront se
terminer par
un point barre benoît réponse est prêt
on est prêt quel genre de choses
désagréables dit on souvent de vous
connard connard
hier matin la salle par la ringarde mais
connard sa marge ont marqué il marque un
point on commence à jouer et c'était le
tour de chauffe pas
quelle personnalité même riez vous pas
croisé salle dans une rue sombre en
giscard oui
la gamme joey starr oui joeystarr c'est
que dans joint via ses marques ses
marques hier marc ménard oui oui
benefit whatwg total quelle personnalité
savez-vous limites et
daniel beasche alger ils marchent pas
manquer à marrakech a pris la main
l'autre va façonner excuses - genre on
enchaîne
c'est quoi
ce genre dans son vieux pardessus rap et
ils s'en allaient l'hiver l'été
quel film avez vous un peu honte d'aimer
le cafard ah oui un super film super
super
classe e fille je demande à dieu a bien
sonné note
senior est ce qu'on leur accorde le
point ou pas
monfils
il ya deux mecs ya dieu si tu avais pas
là jésus est très copain qui me l'avait
attention parmi les ans à jésus est un
bâtard
dieu
dieu est ce qu'on peut dire des choses
comme ça
excusez moi seigneur c'est juste pour
mes points est ce que je leur donne leur
donne pas on peut pas accepter cette
seconde
oh là là
ça commence il envoie un foudre apprête
à des gens plus d'électricité
alors moi je ferai attention quel film
vous a déjà fait pleurer
moyens tu chies tard le désert des
tartares
j'ai tapé en même temps la non
adaptation marche pas le point pour
claude et ryan voilà
alors quel plat savez-vous cuisine
d'apparat le steak tartare mais attends
j'ai très peur
on a frappé avant
moi c'est moi qui la barre
ils n'en sont pas
[Applaudissements]
james se faire escroquer comme ça va
venir si lointain tu vois là en plus
rapide que
j'adore
arrêtez vous faites vos jeux j'appelle
dieu non quelle chose aimeriez-vous voir
disparaître de la surface de la terre
les albums de ben ammar mais les albums
[Applaudissements]
attention à pas mal parce qu'il
concentre toi mais ça marche ou
pas j'ai logé n'avez vous jamais
utiliser
l objet n'avait jamais utilisé comme
sextoys à un plumard ouais non non tu
retires une adresse à genoux allaient
plier la la guitare à la guitare la
guitare à ça ça passe ça ces crédits
j'aimerais bien avoir la gueule
la ville
[Applaudissements]
d oran
[Rires]
nucléaire ni bouton blanc n'échappe
[Applaudissements]
attendez auquel rockhal un minable art
est mort il est chouette tu vois un gars
mais on dit par huawei
[Applaudissements]
moi je peux
alors à l'issue de cet art dit quizz
vous semblez
26 points
et on n'a pas bougé et lui dise elle n'a
pas bougé
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas grave c'est bon je donne ma
promo changeait pas de provence man
legends la mienne attention
et maintenant
on a cassé ce monsieur nous terminons
cette émission avec la grande finale de
l'happy hour
attention le music quiz
attention attention à ce que chacun
d'entre vous aura le choix entre deux
thèmes la production est très généreux
c'est bien tout le monde joue en même
temps et ses deux poings par bonnes
réponses qui veut dire que j'avais 26
610 et paris bien sûr que nous on est
nul là dedans quand vous avez la bonne
réponse vous appuyez sur le buzzer on
commence avec vous c'est et feindre
merde qu'est ce que vous choisissez je
donne deux catégories y est donnez moi
tous la maison pour l'immobilier ou
l'anniversaire parce que vous détestez
deux jours notre affaire c'est le seul
jour où je suis déprimé l'anniversaire
l'anniversaire chez universo ouais ouais
bonne espérance à vous faire gagner bien
sûr voilà attention je tape andrew tap
to shoot à 8 à celui qui est pensé dans
la réponse tape on va paraître bien vide
l'interprète
d'i wanna
c'est bon
ça
il a fait
ce qui marche la marche le mieux
attendez vous david
et
[Musique]
c'est pas mon époque là franchement
franchement c'est bien bien l'ajout ceci
n'a donné pour l'anniversaire de sarkozy
de
rejoindre mercredi mais aurait pas renié
attention genre un peu dessus à dire le
deuxième thème on voit la zone orange
votre autobiographie où la nostalgie
pour l'algérie le ranger lors 11 tu
préfères l'orangé vous faire l'orangé
d'algérie tu t'en fous non pas du tout
et toi ouais
attention l'ange david
descente hommes et sa magnifique chanson
[Musique]
que
il est 15e marys ont
allez bien c'est un très bon chanteur
ouais mais ça veut pas dire quel est le
point quand même en vous avez pas nous
avoir la
gêne mais la petite discussion gens les
ans le café jeu appelle une dernière
fois
je moi te dire angie encore une fois tu
as french man ça me gêne mais bon qu'est
ce que je fais je redonne le poids qui
je donne le viol de nombeuses il promis
il faut bouger vos propos
merci
[Applaudissements]
tu remarqueras qui coule à pic un mec
j'appelle trois foires aux soirées jeux
non mais moi je suis fier pas croire en
dieu bah moi j'y crois énormément
attention david
[Musique]
dung quât prête
ça parle d'anges
tu rêves ou
ayvaz allez va
l'argent
catherine ribeiro je ne veux rien
n'assure
plus jamais personne je n'ai plus cher
non katrina
[Musique]
je souffre la période couplage ça
souffle à soufflage à perdre la musique
pop seulement derrière je me sens
[Musique]
plus jeunes
ont soufflé est pourquoi nous avons
hélas soufflé
l'attaquant ben souffle à
ses jetons et liane foly d'ailleurs j'en
passe très bien la preuve que ce n'est
même pas des chansons mais non c'est pas
obligé toutes les chambres à sucer la
plus belle si l'une des plus belles avec
au fur et à mesure le furet les
magnifiques
attention le troisième serait trop
facile on va écouter une cover comme ça
une cover une reprise kovac attention
david eut volé violé en
sachant benguigui
[Musique]
t'aurais pas mis un filtrage à l'algérie
non le range c'est bien celle orange
c'est beau c'est tourné en même temps
c'est mon livre comme thème pas sûr de
faire de gros mots c'est pour ça je
changeais de ma mère ils sont en train
de vous êtes à
23,6 mccauley les calories dix ans on
est vraiment bien claudia choisissez
quoi alors j'ai des chanteuses qui
assument leurs rondeurs
j'ai appelé sarraut où des gens joyeux
vous êtes très joyeuse jean joël vivre
extraordinaire j'apprends des gens
joyeux les gens joyeux attention david
soufflage
télébec
michel fugain à l'ats michel fugain et
pas elle pas philippe lavaud a dit
philippe lavil tu peux te tromper comme
massey ça m'arrive de me tromper je suis
gentil je mets que vous nous rattraper
pour que ce soit intéressant le début
avec un bijou un
mais choqué les gens dont
michel fugain
attention le deuxième type
là bim
[Musique]
ton plein fouet yes
la liste divers et abidal
fabregas
ce mouvement vers les points
bas vous revenez parce que ils sont à 32
7 à 27 on n'est pas voilà vous êtes
tallard maintenant on va vous prouver
c'est un titre qui est tellement facile
facile car je bosse
que j'ai fait j'ai pris unique over en
fait j'étais
encore je venais à près de l'original
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr ce serait
trop combien sur david
[Musique]
mais
il prendra pas la provocation la cover
et elwood kid qui a filmé cover
extraordinaire il ya maintenant 34 27 la
yann
la naissance dans l'ue ou la littérature
la littérature pour faire plaisir là
la littérature chanson c'est marrant
david
[Musique]
parfait pour maintenant attention à tout
ça maintenant on est vraiment attaquer
ce qui
l'énervé
gfr c'est comme un jeu je suivais match
de tambourin mais c'est mon budget et un
bouquin gauche
attention tous les cas pas ici attention
david
chers certes
c'est française grâce à ses français
monsieur c'est compliqué un ans
pas de soufflage vous laisse
[Musique]
l'un des plus beaux champions
mais partout désordre photo by usure et
j'adore marc lavoine
marie maison parking des anges
de satan elle a les yeux revolver c'est
pour les saints
là les yeux oui mais regarde moi bien
beau job
on n'est pas patient le troisième titre
mondial le troisième set je le trouvais
tellement facile ce que j'ai pris et une
cover david
[Musique]
c'est comme ça
non
attention monsieur pas malin comme
jamais
[Musique]
i
cb
une chanson de deuil avant bravo y
aller dîner chanteur vivant
récap des scores on obligeait way 38,3
pour vous mes amis
moi une formidable je vais gagner haut
la main ces gens là font 29 prenez
c'est donc vous de bien qu'ils allaient
faire avec yann le plus de promo mais
d'abord le rappel de la promo des
perdants suffisait de le faire mettez
vous à la place bon stéphane plaza a
bossé sur m6 oui encore way et au
théâtre à gauche on se retourne
l'ascension voilà benguigui votre
bouquin c'est chez fayard kifaya ça
s'appelle un parfum d'orange amère
non mais bon claudia la sienne
vous êtes une très bonne
une humoriste trop ici je comprends
pourquoi arthur ne peut plus se passer
de vous pourquoi alain delon vous a
roulé une pelle en direct quand je vous
vois je comprends vous jouerez les
dernières prestations de votre spectacle
que j'adore crécy aux folies bergères
voyageurs sur le dab mais piana si
vraiment c'est une soirée un bon
le 29 janvier le 1er février allez-y moi
j'ai vu le spectacle je suis régalé et
je conseille vraiment à tout le monde
gueule tu mets vous marrer
une bonne soirée allez-y
[Applaudissements]
promo
attention vial j'ai décidé d'offrir ma
propre voix jean benguigui
[Musique]
donnez votre commentaire
d'abord parce que j'en ai pas
particulièrement en ce moment et puis
parce que c'est quelqu'un que j'estime
énormément ah bon il était un grand taxi
n'ai jamais vu ça quelqu'un qui donne
quelque chose à quelqu'un d'autre dans
le monde de la télévision c'est très
très rare
50 sortir
jean
genre c'est tout simple sinon on aurait
aimé avoir on le voit dans un film ou
sur scène et celui-là le sourire nous
vient des convois de la bienveillante
pourquoi on t'aime jouer la comédie
c'est sa grande passion et ça se voit
quand on lit sa merveilleuse
autobiographique paru chez fayard un
parfum d'orange amère et franchement
c'est un magnifique cadeau pour tous les
gens de là-bas comme et puis les autres
aussi pour tout et pour tout le monde
c'est universel mais c'est des
sentiments qui touche tout le monde ça
vous met la ça vous met les
larmes aux yeux
j'espère abruzzes avait passé une nuit
en mer
le plus haut
au togo le plus gros
[Applaudissements]
l'animateur l'équipe d'hanovre on sait
le plus grand mais pas du tout c'est par
le mouvement
nairobi c'est le plus grand de tous les
temps ses jambes et je dis merci
ce qui valut à dire cette émission
n'oubliez pas
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
peu de bleu